first cosmo named the kardashians
america's first family back in 2015 and
now interview magazine is declaring kim
kardashian america's new first lady i
love that
[Music]
here's kim k channeling jackie o on the
cover of the mag september issue the
reality star paid homage to one of the
country's most iconic first ladies
posing with her four-year-old daughter
northwest by her side
i want to wear things that make me feel
good about myself the mom of two wore
several perfectly tailored dresses
paired with classic long white gloves
from jackie kennedy's signature big hair
to her chic style we think kim k pulled
off the presidential look
go for it
well the photo shoot is already
receiving backlash online with many
calling it an insult to real life first
lady melania trump
inside the mag kim gets candid about her
family and business she said if her life
as a beauty guru didn't work out she
would want to be a publicist quote i
feel like that's my job for the family
sometimes at least the crisis part of it
she also claps back at the haters who
said she had no talent adding quote you
can say a lot of things about me but you
cannot say i don't work hard i don't
sing i don't dance i don't act but i am
not lazy
i learned from seeing both of my parents
work really hard
[Music]
you